all right welcome back to my channel
today we are going to coat some
JavaScript because it's been a damn long
time I haven't been coding you know
because I work as a data scientist and
by data scientists I made a data analyst
but you know we call it data scientist
at Silicon Valley because we get to get
paid more if we're called data
scientists so pretty much any 12 year
old can actually do my job but we still
get paid a shit-ton to do it so oh wait
just a minute so this video is sponsored
by Wix code and I'll talk about this
right now so you guys know what Wix is
right the website that allows you to
make stunning websites well now they
have Wix code which allows us holders to
tinker with the backend so that we can
do so much more so I could finally do so
much more by adding a database adding
user forms and using javascript and
their api so i could finally make
interactive websites so check this out I
just made a database right here and then
on my home page I connect it to the data
set so now whenever someone writes me a
message it pops up right here once I
finish this website I'm gonna have a
personal wall so I can display all the
awesome messages and support that you
guys gave me right here on this website
so click on the link on the description
to get started with your website today
anyways I really missed coding so if you
missed part 1 in part 2 you should go
check that out but I'll just give you a
quick summary of what I'm building
previously on kookiest coding JavaScript
I wanted to make an app where you can
synchronize watching YouTube between
your friends so I used a YouTube API to
create a player and then I also made a
play and pause button so that I could
send a custom request back to the server
that could synchronize between the
players
alright leggo my eggo my personal my
shoes oh come on I turn okay alright
let's take a break alright so there's
something important I want to talk about
some a lot of people mentioned that I
opened the banana it's not open it's
peel you idiot that I opened the banana
wrongly oh well guess what
you're wrong oh well guess what your
English is wrong idiot because that's
how monkeys open it okay you have to
pinch it from here not from here like if
I want to open it oh crap okay that was
a lot easier than I thought but usually
it's really hard especially if it's not
right it's like oh my god it's so hard
to open it here's how you actually peel
a banana Wow good job you finally use
the word peel you just pinch it right
here there you go it's so much easier
okay see see how much effort it took it
took so much effort and now imagine if
you want to okay okay imagine if you
want to pass the banana to someone else
pass it to me now oh no you dropped it
like how the hell am I supposed to hold
it alright now try this one wow it's
like if there's a cane folded properly
I'm gonna do it again
oh good this is so hard hold her like
this
[ __ ] man get one two three okay
wow thank you look at that good thing
there's an end good thing I could hold
the tail and makes it so much easier to
pass a banana around so there you have
it
that's
[Music]
all right okay okay all right let's code
for real now man you know I realized
there are so many different ways of
sitting and I feel like each way
determines your personality a little bit
let me tell you what I mean the super
straight up stance super economic their
chest is popping elbows aligned with
desk I hate those people they're so nice
to you and perfect
they're probably secretly a serial
killer no one is that economic and I do
not believe that's comfortable at all
now that's the stance I believe in
perfectly snug optimal for coding
efficiently
I think that's being true to yourself
and then there's some people that never
wear shoes for some reason and they love
to put their feet up it's like they
watch too much def note or something and
they think they're quirky and totally
random and then there's this guy who's
super stressed keeps pulling his hair
you know swears from time to time you
know he just looks miserable and then we
got this guy whose mouth is always open
like 24/7 it's probably a gamer or
something it's just so concentrated but
come on man just close your mouth okay
okay okay for real now let's start
coding for real all right so let's go to
the to the web app oh whoops I did not
start it npm start all right great great
we have it on here so the first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna add a
click event on all these buttons like
for example play and stop so right now
if you click these you know it doesn't
really do anything but what we want to
do is that each time we click the play
or the pause button we send it to the
server so the server can send it to
everyone
that's logged in all right let's do that
[Music]
all right cool so now that we got the
buttons working we're going to send this
message back to the server
but first the server has to receive it
so you know just just just wait a minute
you know it takes me some time to read
[Music]
okay god I got it
[Music]
and then now the front end when you
receive these messages you have to act
on it so for example if you receive a
play request I'm gonna play my video if
you receive a pause request I'm gonna
pause my video let's do that
[Music]
I swear
[Music]
shooter
[Music]
[Music]
because I'm playing with
[Music]
all right so let's check my Twitter all
right Thank You Jake for the support
really really appreciate it and then
also we have one question by Sam Shawne
what tools do you use for data
visualization for me I use mostly
tableau and Excel so it's super easy to
use I don't even have to write code for
it so alright thanks for watching this
video if you liked it don't forget to
like to subscribe
and yes see you later Oh
this video is sponsored by wicks cold
wow I didn't expect that you are like
how are you related to me
we're friends are we yes and also I mean
I kind of have to be I also decide about
your career yes and if you're going to
get promoted
but fired if you want him to get demoted
fires fired